[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fed adopter le point de vue d'un
chercheur scientifique extraterrestre
tiendrait sur terre et qui se dira est
assez bizarre alors que nous on n'est
pas étonné donc d'autres prévenus je
vais dire des choses qui vont être des
pâtes étude des évidences et je vais
m'attarder sur les détails qui n'ont
aucun intérêt
comme ça on est tranquille dont je veux
démarrer avec le fait suivant chez les
humains on trouve un système nerveux
central piloté par un cerveau le cerveau
sur terre ça sert à à bouger un un
organisme qui a un cerveau sur terre
mais ils bougent puisqu'il voit pas ça
n'a pas de cerveau bon à part les kinder
et les radiers remet ça c'est des trucs
bizarres mais en général ça sert à ça
et chez les animaux un petit peu plus
structuré compliqué et les humains oui
faire autre chose en plus le cerveau
produit des inférences des images
mentales est le produit d des
commissions c'était un ca et notamment
avec les influx sensorielle qui rentre
dans le cerveau il produit des
opérations d'intérêts les programmes ou
welt
c'est un mot allemand n'ayez pas peur
souvenirs monde interne demande interne
c'est là où on fume aux opérations
mentales
on calcule des choses en calcul si une
balle va à telle vitesse et dans ta
trajectoire comment est ce qu'on pourra
la récupérer et du vin pour ça
facilement les humains utilisent ça pour
leur motricité
pour l'heure le réflexe et pour les
réactions des autres
le but de l'humain c'est d'anticiper ce
qui va autour de lui pour être encore en
vie
dans cinq minutes oui là il a très mal
c'est un humain qui courent pourquoi et
donc il y a un truc où les humains
excellent plus qu'ailleurs c'est
reconnaître les visages humains
il en voit partout c'est un peu comme si
les évolutions avaient mais tous les
points de compétence dans la compétence
reconnaissance des visages c'est le truc
ils sont très forts pour ça alors il
voit des visages tenez vous bien dans
les nuages dans le ciel dans les objets
dans les légumes
et s'il y avait des humains dans la
salle il serait 100% à voir que le
poivron est en colère et que la tomate
et rentrer triste 1 et ils font ça comme
ça donc ils voient des mains partout
c'est plus fort qu'eux et il va pas s'en
empêcher
c'est pas très grave en plus c'est pas
grave et donc on peut expliquer sa part
leur histoire révolutionnaire que les
humains c'est une espèce grégaire une
vie en pack est toujours entre les uns
sans les autres
depuis des millions d'années est donc la
principale ressource pour un humain ou
moins près humain c'est un autre humain
pour interagir pour faire du troc pour
collaborer pour aller tuer un mammouth
voir des choses pour se reproduire
c'est très utile et le principal danger
pour un humain c'est aussi un autre
humain parce que y'a pas un animal sur
terre qui peut tuer autant du minck un
humain donc quand on est un humain on a
plutôt intérêt à anticiper comment se
comportent les autres humains donc à
repérer sur leur visage notamment le
leur revenant c'est assez normal et des
humains font des trucs intéressants
c'est qu'ils font des machines qu'ils
appellent intelligente on en parlera
mais et donc des machines qui les
battent aux échelles qui les battent au
jeu de go donc lorsque le jeu et à des
règles très simples il n'y a pas de
calcul et machine va très bien il ya
aucune machine le monde qui vous hri 10
qui vous dira que le poivron en colère
ou la tomate électrique et risque alors
on peut aller encore plus loin
si des humains regarde cette image à
droite très longtemps enfin quelques
secondes ils vont commencer à être
triste pour l'automate
c'est de l'empathie c'est mystérieux non
ça va ces mêmes les humains très con on
compte de l'empathie - mais quand même
donc les images font des trucs très
bizarre très très jeune les humains
savent rire les bébés avant de parler
savent rire on pourrait trouver enfin
bombay et regarder autour d'eux mais les
bébés sourds savent rire donc ils n'ont
pas appris à le faire spontanément une
produit ce comportement et ils savent
qu'en rire et quand pas rire ils savent
qu'en pleurer sur mon profil
les parents qui sont là le ça va aller
ça marche plus mais voilà les enfants
savent pleurer et des enfants très
jeunes on a remarqué qu'ils savent lire
des relations dit de hiérarchie entre
différents humains et ils savent
reconnaître un gentil ya un méchant il
préfère les gentils pourvu que ça dure 1
et quand ils grandissent les humains ont
qu à partir de l'adolescence commencent
à s'intéresser à des choses et donc ils
nous souhaitent une promiscuité avec
leurs congénères du sexe opposé souvent
et ils apprennent à reconnaître des
caractères anatomiques ou sociologiques
ou comportementaux qui qui manifestent
le bons reproducteurs
donc ils savent reconnaître le bon
partenaire sexuel et ils ont très bon
goût d'un vent devient son mental pour
le réalise un très bon goût et les
humains et ils sont capables de donner
un nom à ça il appelle ça être sexy
et ça marche très bien il se trompe
rarement 1
par contre quand on leur demande un même
les ados très très con ils savent
reconnaître qu'ils sexy qu'il l'est pas
c'est facile quand on est nommé mais
c'est quoi être sexy lors comme réponse
on obtient avant elle est canon points
ça ne s'explique pas ou bien mais enfin
la regarder ou bien arrête tu es con
donc ils savent sans se tromper voir qui
est sexy qui ne l'est pas et sexy ça
enveloppe tous les caractères qui se
font aider mon producteur mais savent
pas pourquoi ça se passe dans leur
cerveau c'est en coulisse et des humains
savoir les sexy mais savent aussi voir
que les gens sont en colère sont
impatients sont affamés sont joyeux sont
stressés sur une scène tu es disent
avoir spontanément ça va
arrêtez ça me laisse aller bien et donc
ils le font facilement grâce à un module
qu'ils ont qui s'appelle la théorie de
l'esprit donc j'ai pas le temps de te
parler mais en gros c'est super ils
savent inférées les états mentaux
interne des gens quand ils la regardent
voilà et en plus ce sont des neurones
miroirs quand je fais ça vous fait part
dans votre tête c'est fatigant et ils
font ça sans aucun effort et ce que
j'aime vous raconter devant une audience
humaine ça serait totalement banale c11
strictement aucun intérêt c'est pour ça
que c'est intéressant parce que si c'est
banal et que pourtant c'est quand même
moi c'est qu'en fait on est dans le
domaine de l'aisance cognitives c'était
le titre de la conférence
dans un courrier arrive les orchidées
c'était un certain sentiment c'est un
matériau monde part en morceaux
c'est un sentiment de ou de bien-être
lorsqu on mettrait une situation ce qui
n'est pas du tout mon cas avec cette
télécommande
voilà de bien-être on se sent bien on
est en maîtrise les sessions en contrôle
et donc en installant des vérités plus
ça me paraît simple à penser plus à me
paraît vrai si je vous répète plein de
fois plus apparaître encore le sens
apparaît encore plus vrai donc et donc
on a une zone de confort coup on est en
sécurité on pense que tout ce qu'on
pensait forcément vrai et donc en fait
on assez compliqué à expliquer cacher je
vais articulé et la complexité en fait
c'est un système qui est instable
il ya plein d'endroits où ça pourrait
mal se passer ça pourrait poser des
problèmes et donc on a plein d'occasions
de se tromper en appelant ce sont donc
les humains passent leur temps à se
tromper c'est pas grave c'est pas un peu
désert mais non loin des petites erreurs
et a parfois une erreur grave une erreur
très grave et personnellement parce que
comme on est dans la zone de contrôle la
zone de confiance la zone de vérité
on cherche pas à vérifier puisque
compenseront la raison
donc on a un phénomène étonnant qui la
persistance des croyances fausses
qui ne se produit pas quand c'est
compliqué mais c'est comme c'est simple
montre les humains sont des mots
étonnants
ils vont persister dans des erreurs là
où c'est le plus simple de ce que régime
mais ne feront pas
vous envie de conduire on le reconnaît
toussaint on passe au dimanche en
famille parfois on voit bien
le dimanche sur terre c'est laid c'est
l'illustration du domaine est donc cette
persistance dans l'erreur c'est plus
fort qu il peut pas faire autrement
parce qu'ils ont le sentiment d'être
dans le vrai et donc le cerveau humain
basse et d'un marteau qui ne croit qu'à
des coups partout et donc les humains en
ces comportements maintenant ils parlent
à leur voiture pour qu'elle démarre à
l'est titine
les humains en gueule leur téléphone
quand elles marchent pas les humains
quand il se cogne dans une table basse
ils ont mal à leur taille mais ils ont
un goal la table basse qui réagit très
peu et et ils traitent leurs animaux
comme les humains ce qui n'est pas un
service alors en bref ils traitent les
nonnes agents comme des agents ont réagi
et c est ça leur paraît mais alors
parfaitement normal vers la salle et
c'est peut-être un peu glousser mais
franchement vous n'importe où sur terre
c'est par un jour normal personne vous
dire assez bizarre tout le monde a
prononcé sur terre cette phrase enfin ce
presque ou entendu sans le son que ça
les choque la télé ne veut pas s'allumer
c'est con donc les humains passent leur
temps à halluciner de l'humain partout à
l'usiné des choses qui ne sont pas réels
et par exemple sur cette image le
cerveau humain a du mal
il ya des différentes zones dans le lobe
occipital qui gère les couleurs et les
formes et les et là on a l'impression
que ça bouge cette image fx ça ne bouge
pas mais si vous faites un peu comme ça
devant l'image ça tourne bon donc le
mouvement n'existe pas mais vous le
percevez réellement tous là vous êtes de
table on voit mal un pas la même forme
à gauche la table est allongée elle est
étroite alors qu'elle est large mais si
je redresse la table à droite comme ça
et que je montre à quoi ressemble le
plateau c'est la même forme géométrique
en bas on le voit on le voit plus quand
on le sait on voit quand même que c'est
pas la même table donc les humains sont
incorrigibles
ils ne peuvent pas voir l'image telle
qu'elle est et il s'en en plus
donc ils perçoivent de plus deux tables
sont différentes alors qu'elles ne le
sont pas
donc tous les humains perçoivent des
choses irréelles mais ils les perçoivent
a réellement et ça leur est naturelle et
simple
et puis c'est simple c'est vrai donc
conclusion quand vous avez un sentiment
de contrôle de confort et que ça vous
paraît vrai c'est pas corrélés il ya une
croix se dire que c'est pas corrélés
voilà donc conclusion qu'est ce qui se
passe quand vous avez le sentiment
d'avoir une vérité absolue dans un
confort absolu et sans aucun effort les
humains devraient avoir envie
[Musique]
plus jeune ils le font bien d'ailleurs
six ans après arrête d'être perplexe
d'être sceptique et de se poser les
questions et donc nous avons conclu nous
étreint terrestre que l'espèce humaine
pourraient être sauvées si je mets le
mérite si les humains commencent à se
poser la question suivante donc votre
espèce dépend de la 1 comment est ce que
je sais ce que je sais c'est que plus ça
paraît simple sa part est vrai mais pas
forcément en fait voilà
[Applaudissements]